good morning good morning good morning
good morning John oh good morning good
morning John
good morning John good morning John I'm
back home and I missed good morning John
I'm back home and I'm good morning John
it's Sunday I'm back home and I missed
you so much that I was watching our
video that we did together and I noticed
how much funny stuff there was that
didn't get to go in the video so I'm
making this special Sunday video in
which all I'm doing is putting the funny
parts that we didn't put in into this
video and it's pretty short but I enjoy
it I hope you enjoy it and that's all
I'm gonna do John we'll see you tomorrow
alright just what just record for 20
minutes everything we are about to say
shall be funny we need to come in and
out in today's video comes to you in
three parts part one on announcement
part two hey Tom not ready years
nerdfighteria has been taking over to
just burp no but I'm going to cut you
off at so I can say that part okay yeah
fine we were just talking to YouTube on
the telephone they were like hey and
yeah that's actually yeah we just we're
talking to YouTube no big deal all of
you will make videos on December 18th
pleased or you're ruining everything
ah this is my video now and we'll be
announcing more things in the future
that was very eloquent at the end
particularly I moved and for those of
you don't know what the project for
awesome
and for those of you who don't know what
the project for awesome is we're putting
videos and for those of you who don't
know what the project for awesome and
for those of you don't know it and for
those of you who don't know much about
the project and for those of you and for
those of you don't know what the project
for awesome video odd said this 45 times
part 2 a challenge we will allow you to
challenge us to do something horrible
and when he says us I think he just
means him is that truth I'll do
something horrible to I'll do something
more horrible it's true you always do
something more I love the horrible
things I'm a masochist burned through
the vital announcement burnt through the
final amount burnt through the phyto
blown out
I'm gonna make actually I'm just gonna
just stupid a pig's fifty it's all gonna
be out since it's always I feel like I
invented the giant squid of anger so
that bond L okay so quick recap
dftba.com slash sale for your okay so a
quick recap dftba.com for your t-shirt
needs wrong okay we've been doing this
for four years you're not on the screen
right no I don't know how like I I think
I just keep like pushing you out like
enough frame is mine alright so quick
recap dftba.com slash sale for your
t-shirt needs moon pause no moon pies
are a real thing in the South John I'll
see you sometime
well I mean why just as soon as we turn
off the camera will probably continue
the CICU right I know I feel like you
see me last night Hank and Catherine
were being their typical sort of lefty
namby-pamby selves and Catherine was
like I want to thank the fish and then
my wife was like I see you fish dftba
nerdfighteria we'll see you on Monday
we'll see you on Monday we'll get you
I'll see you on Monday we should redo
that last part